Я хотів би підтримати ініціативу
Зеленського
ініціативу про перезавантаження влади і
тут мова точно не йде про лапутіну бо за
два тижні дета річниця розстрілу
Небесної Сотні І ради пам'яті перших
жертв російської агресії слід очистити
всі держави установи в першу чергу офіс
президента від недолюстрованих
недобитків команди Януковича ставленіків
партнова
мене аж тремтить про те що нас будуть
вітати з річницею Небесної Сотні От такі
які зараз щей голос насмілюються
подобати перестановки необхідні і в
кабміні аж до заміни його на
технократичний уряд і Я дуже сподіваюся
що це буде здійснено шляхом формування
уряду національної єдності А зеленському
зараз в цих критичних умовах варто
запросити лідерів парламентських фракцій
для того щоб говорити рішучі дії для
укріплення
обороноспособності обороноздатності
держави і ще одне Почніть з себе а
залужного
від
чепитись